this is Startalk Gabe Szabo yes Gabe
Gabe's costner yeah yes Gabe is coming
to us from Facebook and says need a
straight answer here bill what equals a
GMO and what equals selective breeding
where is the line drawn well that's a
great question
Gabe what really is a great question
let's go Gabe you show off yeah yeah
it's really good because okay go ahead
this is this is the question when I
wrote this chapter in the first version
of my book about evolution I had a
pretty clear idea in my mind about
distinction the distinction was whether
or not humans were influencing it that
was my idea that influencing the genome
so if you breed within the species you
shade like George Washington used to
take tweezers and a magnifying glass and
shake the pollen from one wheat plant
onto the eggs the OVA of another to get
a hybrid a new type of wheat that was
within the species intraspecies right
and I thought to myself taking a gene
from another species let's say the
bacillus thuringiensis bacterium and
putting it in corn BT corn okay that
would be just a PE T corn no no that's
that's different yeah that's a
television yeah that's outlet yeah
exactly and I don't know what their
relationship means they have bad jokes
but I don't know if that's the same as B
et corn okay
corny television right but we all have
bad jokes that would be an example there
right there so anyway I thought when I
wrote the chapter I thought well that's
not I'm it's a clear distinction rather
that one's genetically modified in an
extraordinary way okay
by bringing a gene from another genome
and another species and putting it into
species of interest compared with
shaking the pollen in the OVA which
would be intra within the species go
ahead it has been pointed out to me that
that happen that these species insert
their genes into each other all the time
in nature and when I started the
research
I know that no I want you to think that
way I want you to think that makes for
lively speculation anyway so if you ever
see a Gaul on the side of a tree the big
bowl the bolt that's where a virus has
not only infected the tree but gotten
its genes into the trees cells nice but
then as I was finishing research and
turning in the final the bird final the
last manuscript version of the
manuscript this fabulous research came
out about sweet potatoes and so it turns
out the sweet potatoes that you and I
know and love and presuming that you
know them and love them I do indeed
though it's very difficult for a black
person not to know and love sweet
potatoes it's just part of our culture
okay well I i I'm substantially Bantu
according to a genetic research Aneta
casts a that was done on me uh-huh and
but I love sweet potato there you go
glad incidence what'd I tell you we're
incident what I say to my fellow brother
so that aside this is genes from outside
the sweet potatoes clearly got in there
naturally naturally so that humans
accelerate it
you can argue quite strongly and for me
convincingly that this is what humans do
we hybridize plants either the
old-fashioned way George Washington's
tweezers ins and magnifying glasses
right glass or the modern way with
biotechnology so what has happened at
companies like pioneer seeds which part
of DuPont ConAgra and especially
Monsanto they have made the transition
from being chemical manufacturers
industrial chemical manufacturers
fertilizer and pesticides into a biotech
firms right and so you go there
everybody all the scientists are
geneticists that's who they hire they're
not chemists as so much anymore this
is Startalk